socialism that you talked about earlier
you know uh the ccp in particular uses
those confucian origins to spread
socialism they said socialism is just
the logical
economic implementation of confucianism
and
you are in that upbringing in that
environment where you're getting picked
on constantly the the upper class or
reminding you of how poor you are you're
feeling
very very helpless in that moment you
are
right for the picking for you know
extremist communist socialist ideology
you are their their top target and yet
you
from from from what i know about you
you're a pretty staunch anti-socialist
how did those two things come about
well socialism when imprisoned my family
socialism is what murdered my family um
i saw the genocide i saw the
the um
the oppression
from it
so i felt that energy it's not like i'm
reading a socialist ideology i've seen
it firsthand i've seen it around the
world i've seen
communist countries
you know i've been to 27 countries
you know communism in
uh was our primary enemy when i first
came in we would study
the sounds of helicopters and vehicles
of russian
tanks
russian helicopters we would close our
eyes and and hear russian helicopters on
a on a headset and we have to write down
what we're hearing and the distance
we're hearing from and
and the directions coming from so what
i'm saying to you is we study russian
doctrine because that was our enemy
it's always been our enemy we took our
eyes off the ball
i have a question for you regarding
patriotism right so i totally understand
why you would have no love for communism
or socialism that's literally what
killed your family and friends back in
vietnam but
to use gerard's example juxtaposed that
with coming to america this capitalism
uh home of capitalism
and
there you are eight years old getting
spit on called the
beat up
you know
left her dead
so to speak
where does the patriotism come from that
you say all right i gotta fight for this
country it's like you're almost like a
man without a home where it's like
you're getting kicked out of your
country you come to america they're
literally telling you go back home
how do you become a
american patriot like where does that
come from
i was raised by warriors
i was raised by green berets
i was raised by patriots
i was raised by my grandfather who
fought
in the second world war and
you know the korean wars i was raised by
my father who fought in wars and
defended our our countries and our
freedoms
i had no freedom come in this country so
i know what it means to not be an
american
right i wasn't given
um
you know a status of freedom i didn't
have even a country so when people say
go back to your country we had no
country
we had nothing so
why the patriotism because america gave
me a home when no other country didn't
so no matter how unfairly or unjustly
you're being treated you still loved
america is that fair to say do you do
you believe that
one person as racist towards you
reflects all of americans
do you believe in you know because i
served in the united states army and i
felt racism all through all the way to
the top tier the national asset of
america
do you
stereotype everybody because of one or
two
you know so the thing is this
i'm stronger than hate
i said that when i was eight
so i'm stronger than racism i'm stronger
than oppression i'm stronger than all
these things
did you have friends in school that said
come on too like you're my guy man like
just let's forget about that
over there like let's hang out let's go
like whoa
i was ostracized i was did you have any
friends the kid that was poor that stink
that smelled like fish
i was that
you know that i still make your blood
boil
no
because it's through the struggles you
find your strength so i realized that
unless i faced at a young age i wouldn't
have the the strength i needed to fight
for the oppressed i wouldn't understand
what it means to be that so when when
when i go into a village in africa or in
the philippines and i'm fighting in
zamboanga and these these children lost
their freedoms i can understand at a
deeper level
than anybody else
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]